welcome back everyone we're
delighted to have for the second paper
in this mini workshop uh does public
diplomacy sway foreign public opinion
identifying the effect of high-level
visits
by benjamin goldsmith yusuke horyuchi
and kelly matush
so i believe isako is taking the lead on
the the presentation
of this paper so please uh take it away
okay uh thank you very much for giving
us
giving us an opportunity to present our
paper so this is a paper with ben
ghosen from anu and keri matish from
florida state
and the title of this paper is um
publicly does public diplomacy sway
foreign public opinion
so uh the many governments uh invest
uh significant resources to communicate
with foreign citizens
and at this time of government-sponsored
communication
often called public diplomacy represents
a prominent component of states
uh foreign policy today and public
diplomacy activities include
sponsored educational exchange programs
state broadcasting outlets and cultural
events
and these efforts these efforts are
aimed to shape global affairs
through improving the perception of
their leaders
country people and core values and
increasing
support for specific policies to put it
differently
these diplomatic activities are aimed to
increase
soft power resources which we have been
discussing since the first paper
so this the study of public diplomacy
has bloomed into a substantial
literature
but there is surprisingly little well
identified
evidence about the effectiveness of
public diplomacy
can government actually sway the opinion
of foreign
citizens with such diplomatic efforts
so we argue that this fundamental
question
is essential to understand the impact of
strategic transnational communication in
modern
international relations
so to answer this question we emphasize
the importance of expanding
the scope of public diplomacy studies
broad literature on soft power as you
know
uh is u.s centric in its theoretical
exposition
and empirical studies also tends to be
based on single countries most
often the united states or at most a few
this focus on single country studies or
american software
does not allow us to answer even basic
theoretical questions
about the general use of public
diplomacy for example
questions about japan-china software
competition the topic of the first paper
at this conference
or the impacts of south
south public diplomacy those topics
cannot be well addressed
empirically without a general
understanding of the efficacy
of public diplomacy across countries
so to contribute to the literature of
public diplomacy and soft power
we focus on a major and an irish
tool of public diplomacy that is
high level political leaders visit to
other countries
so our study speaks to several
important issues in international
relations beyond public diplomacy
so transnational communication is seen
as increasingly relevant to
international power in the global
information age
and establishing that leaders can shape
public opinion
abroad is a fundamental step to
understanding
how and when states achieve their
foreign policy goals
in this context more broadly
public support is relevant to a wide
range of international goals
for example existing studies suggest
that public opinion contributes
to a state's policy states policy on
international trade
foreign aid military coalitions and
military bases
as a result cultivating foreign public
goodwill
may assist a state in shaping a partner
state's
ability to implement a desired policy
across a wide range of policy realms
so leaders around the world devote
significant amounts of their limited
time to international travel
according to recent study by malice and
siemens recent u.s presidents
spend up to one-third of their time on
international trips
the primary reason leaders travel
internationally
is to have a closed door negotiation
with host leaders
host country leaders to discuss security
and economic
issues or other issues other important
issues but
during hyderabad visit foreign leaders
engage in extensive public outreach
directly addressing foreign audiences
and
attending public events in front of tv
cameras
for example visiting an
australians may play catch
they may have sushi together at the
famous restaurant
or they may enjoy playing golf together
or the visiting leader may be invited to
attend a sumo tournament
so why do they attend public events
in front of tv cameras given the intense
constraints on their time
the fact that visiting leaders often
spend significant time on public
outreach
while abroad should suggest that they
believe this type of public diplomacy
brings substantial
benefits we argue that
they engage in these public outreach and
image building activities
because visiting leaders want to
influence foreign public
opinion in other words these events
outside closed door meetings are part of
their public diplomacy campaigns
there are two ways visiting leaders can
sway foreign public opinion
first visiting leader tries to increase
awareness of themselves and their
country among
citizens in the host country of
many possible tours of public diplomacy
hierarchy visits are particularly well
suited to gain
the audience attention due to the large
amount of media coverage
they tend to draw second
they try to convey positive messages and
images
often focus on the relationship with the
host country and its leader
by sending these messages they attempt
to increase the likelihood that audience
will
view them and by extension their country
favorably but both pathways are
contingent
on two uh two things
first how the opportunity
just how the opportunity for public
diplomacy are arranged usually host
leaders have their own domestic
incentives to produce
publicly visible and positive visits
produce publicly visit one positive
visit which may
show up their own domestic support as
invited guests of the administration
impala the visiting leaders typically
enjoy some level of endorsement from
their host
increasing their legitimacy in the eyes
of the foreign public therefore in most
cases
the host leader's ability to direct
domestic attention
assists the visiting leaders leader in
their public diplomacy
goals second
the the second is how much and in what
ways the media cover for
leaders visit given the military agreed
nature the visit
and incentives of both leaders the
the media coverage of higher visits
tends to
convey positive messages and images
about the visiting leader
so if these conditions are not met then
a visit will not
occur but to put it differently our
theory
predicts that when public differences
visit actually occur
it is likely that incentives of the
visiting and host leaders are reasonably
well aligned
and the news media allows you to produce
some coverage of the visit
therefore a visit raises awareness of
the visiting
leader among citizens of the host
country and convey
positive messages about that leader to
them so given this theoretically
expecting
expectation our specific hypothesis
are the following hierarchy visits
increase favorable perception of the
visiting leader in that host country
they decrease indifference perceptions
and they decrease
unfavorable perceptions but
increasing by increasing awareness
we think that visit could increase
positive attitude by moving respondents
from indifference
toward a positive opinion by conveying
positive messages we also think that a
visit could decrease
negative attitude
to test these hypotheses
uh we leverage a natural
experimental situation and estimate
causal effects of high revisit using
individual level opinion posts generated
in the real world environment
at the time of high level visits
specifically
we use sorry we use
one of the most extensive cross-national
and individual level data available
uh get out of the post and specifically
the question we use for our analysis
is do you approve or disapprove of the
job performance of the leadership of
the name of a country we combine this
data set with our own original data
concerning high level visits by
political leaders
the identification strategies for causal
influence is to compare the respondents
to this question
between those who are interviewed just
before the first day of a
high level visit and those who are
interviewed just after
if there is uh no other systematic
difference between respondents between
these uh control and human groups
then we can estimate the causal effect
by just simply taking the difference of
means
so the combination of the two data sets
uh provides an opportunity to identify
the causal effect of
visit by 15 leaders
from nine countries over 11 years
to 38 countries and we compare the
approval and or deception of the
visiting leader among
32 456 respondents
interviewed either just before or just
after the first day of a visit
so this table shows a number of cases in
our sample
and before showing the the result of a
statistical analysis
i'd like to focus on one specific case
to illustrate
our research design and some interesting
finding
so a case for this analysis is japanese
prime minister
visit to south korea from to november
1st to november 2nd
in 2015.
so prime minister abe arrived in seoul
on november 1st
2015 and within the five days
before this date 81 korean adults
happened to respond to garage pool uh
instead of uh responding
the garage after the event after the
visit
and among them 72.9 disapproved of the
job performance of
abe only 17.6
percent approved of it
but within the five days after his
arrival
101 korean citizens uh participated in
this survey
importantly the percentage of this
approval dropped to
63.4 the difference is nine percent
point
on the other hand uh the percentage of
approval
increased to 20.8 percent the percentage
of indifference opinions also increased
from 9.4
to 15.8 so these changes are consistent
with our hypothesis
and for this particular case this change
the statistic is significant even for
these 182 respondents
what could explain these changes in
attitudes among korean people
there are some factors that could be
consistent with our findings
the meaning between the leaders of japan
and south korea in 2015
was the first meeting in the three years
there are many contentious issues
particularly the issue about the
so-called comfort women issue
but the leader of the two east asian
countries agreed to improve their
relationship by
continuing the dialogues between two
countries
and the prime minister abe and president
park also smite
and shook their hands and these images
were used in the media
but there are also some other factors
that could be inconsistent with our
findings
during the two day two day visits they
only had one meeting
and no joint statement was made
there was no also no press conference
and typically visiting leaders
participate events to meet a general
public or events to display their
friendly relationship but
these events were not organized at all
but there was an unexpected event after
the meeting
so one of the debates during the
previous arrangement between the two
governments
was to whether to have lunch together
after the morning meeting on november
2nd so the korean government tried to
set this launch
conditional on the japanese government's
pre-visit agreement to make a joint
statement
which would set the target date to find
solutions for the comfort of government
issue
but because obvious said no to such a
compromise
president park missed a chance to set a
friendly lunch for public diplomacy
and after the meeting ended around 11.
11 30 a.m
president park asks uh prime minister of
it so what is your plan after
this after this before your departure
and
as i said we have a korean barbecue
and i went to a restaurant not
necessarily
the very special restaurant in seoul
with people from the japanese embassy
and other delegates and uh we actually
also know how much they paid and they
actually total amount they paid was
about 100 u.s dollars per
person so it's not that expensive oh
actually it's expensive for us
but maybe not so expensive for the
japanese government
and importantly this is the point the
barbecue ranch was widely covered by the
media in korea
the media criticized uh president park
for
not welcoming the guest which is against
the korean culture
while sympathy was directed toward the
prime minister
by having korean lunch instead of for
example going to fancy japanese
restaurant in seoul
at a local restaurant that ordinary
korean citizen can go
abe perhaps succeeded in mobilizing some
favorable
at least not so hostile attitude among
korean citizens
so the example just explained may have
some other idiosyncratic reasons why the
effects are positive
so we pull all 86 cases like this
example and estimate the average effect
of a high level revisit
the statistical method is simple
ordinary discrimination
with a visit specific fixed effects to
see the variations within each visit
and we need to choose the number of days
before and after the first day of the
visit
for the main analysis we choose five
days but we also
show in our paper that affects our
robust dislike changing
in this bandwidth the outcome variables
approval percentage
disapproval percentage and percentage
respondents using neither approval nor
disapproval
the treatment is simply where the
respondents were interviewed before or
after
the first day of each visit
our analysis shows substantial increase
in approval of the visiting leader
this figure shows a 2.3 increase in
approval on
average across all 86 visits
the vertical bars represent 95
confidence interval
if they do not include zero the
coefficients are statistically
significant
and highlighted in red the percentage of
this sub-group disapproval decreases by
1.4 percent the percentage in
differences
also decreases but it is very
insignificant
the effect is substantially large for
example the effects of approval
percentage is
roughly equivalent to 40 41
of average annual change of the approval
percentage
and in addition to being substantively
large
these effects are not fleeting so to
estimate
their duration we use we use a rolling
rolling average based on a five-day
bandwidth
gradually moving farther from the visit
start so one two five two two six six to
seven
and we compare this with the fixed five
day bandwidth control group
immediately prior to the visit so this
figure shows
this result for the three response
categories again statistically
significant
effects are highlighted in red so most
notably
the increasing approval for the visiting
leader is enduring
this effect appears to last up to about
20 days
from the start of the vivid the
reduction in ambivalent
uh responses also lasts for roughly 20
days
and the reduction in support is rarely
short-lived
so if indifferent views are more
more likely to be weakly held
and based on law information which is
our theory then the greater duration of
the effects on these
views suggests that any lasting impact
of a higher
visit operates more through informing
the uninformed than through persuading
those who previously held a negative
review
of the visiting country or its leader
now if our theory is correct a visit
should influence public opinion only if
the media
cover them and in our primary results we
included
all visit regardless of whether we can
confirm any media coverage or publicly
promising activities
but uh to to test the media coverage
effect
we divide all cases into two with or
without evidence of public diplomacy
and then estimated german effects
separately and then the
this figure uh shows and the right panel
shows that
uh in case of evidence of media coverage
of public diplomacy
there is a large and significant
increase in approval and a significant
decrease in other responses
but the the left figure shows
that there is if there is no evidence of
public diplomacy
just simply no effect
so these results suggest the causal
mechanisms involving
visiting a visible public outreach and
news media coverage
uh these are commonly assumed in the
literature
uh help explain the effects we find
so uh given the time consuming i should
skip
the next two slides but this figure
is the first of the two uh figures
showing our sensitivity uh
checks so uh in order to fully
understand that these effects that we
estimate
are effects of public diplomacy
uh in this figure we tried to exclude
some cases of visit like the visit with
the announcement of foreign aid
the visit uh with a certain kind of a
threat
or some other economic deals because
these deals or
foreign foreign aid or even military aid
may
change public opinion but nothing to do
with the public diplomacy
but after excluding these cases we see
the same results
and then this is another uh test it's
also called a
liver one out test uh sensitivity test
so the researchers may suggest that the
public diplomacy
has some effects if the the
visitors are the u.s leaders but in
order to see whether this is driven by
the effects of a particular country
uh we excluded one country one and after
and then we estimated the pegs
but uh the vectors do the same so
meaning that
uh there's no single country uh
driving the average effect that we
produce and we i just presented
so these findings support the core and
the largely
untested assumption behind most of the
literature on public diplomacy
public differences actually sways
foreign public opinion
period and this is also the core
assumption behind the argument that
public diplomacy is an effective tool to
increase the country's
soft power resources okay the effect we
find
is substantial not short-lived and not
specific to the us
and uh given the time constraint i
decided not to
introduce some additional results but in
the paper
we also produ present some results of
exploratory analysis
showing how much defects are conditional
on
for example the relationship between the
host and the visitors
and also the the lengths of office uh
the
uh the how long the visitor is in office
and some other heterogeneous treatment
effects
but if you have any questions about
actually the paper is there so plea
if you're interested in those
conditional uh effects please uh
and read our paper so we believe that
our results
provide a potential avenues through
which
to better understand how public opinion
forms
um on a range of important policy issues
and the impact for empirical opinion
international outcome
is closely tied to the ability to
influence
that opinion which we demonstrate in
this article
so we hope our findings will energize uh
our further investigation into the
nature of foreign public opinion
formation
and its downstream effects on policy
outcomes
thank you great thank you so much
professor oyuchi for that presentation
so now we have three discussions
starting with
professor christina davis
great thank you so much for inviting me
to participate in this workshop really
two great papers
and a fantastic group i
really enjoyed reading the paper
and it is even more rich than this
fantastic presentation we've just
listened to
so while the paper cannot have the
lovely display of korean bbq
it does have even more graphs all query
displaying
a fantastic set of results what i like
about the paper
is it's really nicely connected to the
literature and soft power
while moving forward by focusing in on a
specific mechanism
not just public diplomacy but the leader
visits
and this is really quite interesting
because when we think of soft power as
sort of
slow moving components like culture
it's harder to analyze and
so you both gain better research design
and you gain better
policy implications by honing in on this
aspect
of the leader visits and i really want
to applaud them on that
move for both theory and empirical
research design
and the findings are really quite
interesting to show that there's you
know
an increase in public opinion
favorability
from a visit on the magnitude of 2.3
percentage points which they show
is large relative to the standard
deviation you might see in the movement
of
how much you like trump or how much you
like she
and that's important it's also
fascinating that the visits are
not rewarding the host
in many ways i found that no
finding for the hosts getting a
leadership
bump to be equally fascinating
and so i think you might want to think
more about why that is but
it pays into their idea that it's
increasing attention and appreciation
where perhaps there was less information
and i guess the leader visit showcasing
your own leader showing up at the sumo
match doesn't add any new information
about him
um but that's very interesting
i did want to know um
at a higher level of thinking about
soft power is the ability to change
opinion about
outcomes is the connection that you like
the leader more
you like the country more going to lead
you to have
policy preferences towards more
cooperation and that might be the next
paper
um this paper is already good i just
want to give four quick suggestions of
areas that could be
improved i think that you could clarify
first
what is the appropriate comparison is
your counterfactual
just that there is no visit to some
extent i think
the richness of the paper is trying to
separate
pomp from policy
and the idea of just the visit where you
pose for pictures and the camera
as opposed to policy and yet in some
ways that's disturbing
when you say that offering economic aid
or announcing an agreement is not public
diplomacy
where i would have thought public
diplomacy is very much about
delivering promises of specific
cooperation
and so anyways i think it'd be helpful
to try and think about that if you're
looking at
non-visit or if you're thinking about
within the visit
what share is it how much you offer the
agreements
versus just showing up and looking
sociable
and smiling um and certainly you'd want
to look at the tone of the agreements i
mean
last week's miss visit in alaska was
not exactly a positive meeting of all
smiles when we think about the chinese
foreign minister and tony blinken's
engagement
so you might want to think more about
what are the tones of the agreement
second how do the regime types differ
so if you're thinking about the meetings
you talk about how it shows shared
values
you might draw more on the trevor and
certainly at all
first paper we've just been discussing
about how can a mismatch of values
make soft power possibly even result in
a backlash
and so if you were to think about how
does an authoritarian
dyad have a different response to public
diplomacy
than if it were democratic democratic
and that might get at this you know
are you telling us something different
reversing stereotypes
or because you're different you're
coming and you're criticizing
in which case you might see backlash and
so you might actually have stronger
effects if you were to sort of
parse out these potential different
effects
three says we're all interested in japan
i had to read through the appendixes
which are quite long in detail
and you go through all of the
sensitivity tests to taking out
countries and when you take out the
leader visits by japan
it attenuates the effect size from 2.2
to 1.9
now if i'm interpreting this correctly
it means that actually japan gets a lot
from its visits
and china was the other country that
appears
to have you know taking china out of
your pooled results attenuates the
average effect but maybe i read it too
quickly there
um and then the last point that's really
interesting if you're trying to
go further on some of the details what
is a visit are you having
different types of heterogeneous
treatment effects when you have the
flyover meeting
versus the three day we're going to stop
and
you show that many of the visits were
actually zero
nights meaning it was just a quick
stopover whereas others could be three
days
and i'm a little worried when you're
always measuring interviews as
after the first day sometimes the leader
has already made their press release and
left
other times they're just in the midst
and the press is still rolling on an
ongoing visit and so i think you might
want to
separate that out but um those are in
the details i think overall it's really
fantastic paper and also naima is much
more qualified to think about public
diplomacy and soft power so i should
yield the floor
great thank you uh thank you for seeing
that yeah we will move on to soon to be
professor
uh nina green riley
thanks so much um well i will
echo what christina said by saying that
i
very much enjoyed reading this piece i'd
seen an earlier draft of this it was
shorter
but this version really goes deep on the
question of how foreign leader visits
affect
public opinion about the leader's job
performance and
i think that the paper makes a lot of
really important contributions right
because there isn't very much empirical
work
on the effects of public diplomacy right
now um
the data set and the way that the
authors manipulate
the timing of the interview is
innovative and creative
and um so i have a few comments i'm
gonna divide them into
theoretical comments and then some
empirical comments um
first theoretical comments so you say
in your hypothesis section that the
majority of
messages about a foreign leader that are
in the media
during any visit will be positive and i
think that
that particular point is the point that
gave me the most sort of angst and the
thing that i probably disagreed with the
most
and it the reason i disagreed with that
is i think that i
i worked in some places where we have
hard relationships right but
china and egypt i know that when we had
leader visits
we were always fighting the media like
don't publish that because that's not
true
don't lie about the leader uh don't
say things that that make the leader
look bad and so
that relationship between the media and
the public diplomats is definitely not
one always that's just
one of joy and more related to your
paper
i don't think that the media coverage
will always be positive definitely
when practitioners read this paper they
would also disagree with that point
really strongly
um so to fix that i think if you just
said that the news
coverage of the country and the leader
increases around the time of the visit
and didn't necessarily make that
statement that and
on the whole the coverage is going to be
positive at least
we we know that there will be sort of
this increase in attention towards the
country that's probably true
um secondly you mentioned the host
country leader has an ability to
constrain the public diplomacy success
of the visiting leader in the theory
section
and you go into detail about how uh
there
have been negotiations between like the
u.s and the chinese
on how much public diplomacy one of the
leaders can do
on a trip um but then when i got to the
empirical side i didn't necessarily see
uh any sort of discussion about that
type of thing right so
uh the host leader trying to constrain
the visiting leaders public closely
didn't really show up in the empirics
the paper is really rich i don't know
that my suggestion is to
add more empirics that get to that point
because i'm not sure if your data lends
itself to doing that
but i do think that by raising that
issue and then not
talking about it in the empirics 4. i
had a bunch of questions that then were
unanswered and probably could have been
avoided if
maybe that part weren't in there because
it's not really a part of your fix
anyway
um at the end of the paper you make the
point about
the credibility of the visiting leader
as
measured through the amount of time that
the leader has been in office so really
there's like a section on
the length of time it's it's flipped in
that the section is about the length of
time the
visiting leader has been in office but
then you make sort of a statement that
oh well
it could show that credibility matters
and i'm not necessarily sure that
credibility stems from how long a
leader's been in office right so having
been in
office could for many leaders actually
lead to
a negative effect of their credibility
depending on what they do when they're
in office um
so those are the theoretical comments
for empirics um
i wondered why in your robustness checks
when you add in covariates you only
added in the covariates of the variables
that were not balanced i recognize the
empirical reason for including
definitely the covariates that aren't
balanced but even the covariates that
are balanced in the samples
would be interesting to have in those uh
regression results just because
we're still learning about public
diplomacy so any information we can have
about what different features of people
and respondents
matter to public diplomacy offers i
think is good
i would love to see some information on
the baseline
job assessment or job performance
assessment
of the 15 leaders around the world in
the host countries that you study
and then see evidence from you all that
the
average job performance of the leader in
the countries where you selected so
there are i think 38 countries that you
did your analysis
as opposed to the job assessment
for those leaders sort of globally is
not
different right so what i really want to
see is that
in the countries that you just like
there's a lot of them so there's a good
chance that this will work out fine
but in those 38 countries they're not
more likely to be liked already
that makes sense um on average and then
last thing i'll say i have more comments
but i'll send them to you because i
don't want to spend too much time
is i'm curious about whether there might
be a bias
for democratic leaders in your data so i
was just looking at the
visits that you include in the data set
and um it seemed like there might be
more interest by democratic leaders in
the data set than trips by autocratic
leaders
and if so i just that's i mean that
might be the case and if that's the case
i think you should discuss that i think
you should say you know our data set
skews if it does
um here's a place where that might
matter also so in addition to the fact
that we just want to know that fact
because it
i mean that's your data center we want
to understand what the data set is um
there was a a part of the analysis where
you look
at um places where the visits um were
covered by the media versus when they
weren't
and the uh coverage by the media was
measured through
sort of like these uh this factiva
search of english language sites
um you mention in your in a footnote
that we know that there are some
problems with not including local press
and only looking for english level
news or english language news uh reports
in the footnote
but i would assume that you're writing
that because
the visit could have been covered by
local press and you don't know and so
you're not including the right uh
countries in your sub-sample another
problem with that is that
if you're only looking at english
language uh news sources
then i wonder if your sub-sample is now
more likely to be more favorably
inclined towards democratic leaders
and if your entire set your entire data
set
of foreign leaders tends to be more
demographic democratic than it is
autocratic then you've got some bias
there
i'm gonna stop there i'll send you the
rest via email
great thank you so much uh and then
finally professor tatsu kobayashi
thank you again so i'll keep it brief
because i
already made some comments on the first
paper
uh so the first uh so i have one
methodological
comment and the other is perhaps more
theoretical
so for the first one i might have missed
in your presentation or in the paper but
i i think there's
some sort of the the uh endogeneity
issue because
before the the high level visit of
course there's going to be a lot of you
know careful planning
right so xi jinping you know uh uh has a
plan to visit japan
and of course to to the us but uh his
visit to japan hasn't been realized
because you know the bilateral
relationship
is not so friendly now so in other words
they you know the the host country and
visiting country they both you know
carefully plan in advance
to to make this kind of you know
positive uh
impact of of visiting to be realized
so in other words they so so the the
the cases where there's there's some
kind of you know uh backlash or negative
impact will be
would have been censored already so in
our
only case so we can we can only observe
the cases where
positive consequences are reliably
expected so if that is the case
basically is the outcome i mean the
positive impact on public opinion
is you know uh defining what what
what cases are going to be observed so i
wonder
how you uh uh could deal with this kind
of potential indigeneity issue
uh relatedly um so so you
frame this uh visit as kind of high rank
uh officials visit but
my question related questions how high
it should be
so uh christina already mentioned about
the alaska meeting so there's a so
that's a that's also the visit of the
chinese high-rank officials to the u.s
but it was not a you know president
versus president meeting
uh and then the end result was really
you know not really
friendly so does it have to be that
country leader like a president or prime
minister
or or can we do we observe the similar
effect
for those like at the ministry level uh
visits
um the theoretical question is about uh
the mechanism behind this effect so
overall
i had an impression that most of the
effect is coming from
kind of a name recognition effect
because not many people know about
foreign leaders
but when they visit the their own
countries it's going to be
reported and covered by media so that's
basically for the first time people
realize oh this is a good guy and
you know good leader so i like him i
like her right
but there might be other uh mechanics
potential mechanism for instance
uh the in many visits the visitors
bring some kind of gifts or souvenirs
right
so okay we're going to give you this
foreign aid or we're going to have this
you know uh economic trade deal and so
on so these are again so carefully
crafted in advance of
visits and can we differentiate the
effects
of name recognition from
uh name i mean in fact more substantial
souvenirs
if the name recognition is very strong i
guess you can test it with your own
uh very unique interesting data set
because
some you know uh uh people visited the
same country for multiple times
for instance uh from your table i get i
can see that uh angela
merkel visited belgium for for four
times
for instance if name recognition effect
is the primary uh source of this effect
then the impact would you know basically
decrease
in the second time three times for them
because they all know miracle already
right so uh you can i don't know if it's
uh technically
possible but you may uh uh be able to
capitalize on this multiple visits by
the same visitor to the same country
okay uh i think i should stop here so uh
thank you very much for this very
interesting
study i think so as other
discussions i was so much impressed
because this is a really
unique data set and a combination of the
two sources of data set and the findings
has a huge implication i guess thank you
great thanks to the discussants um we
have already a great
line of people wanting to give comments
so i'll read out the lesson and then
i'll put it in the chat
uh so that people can just um uh
now follow us that's michael tease amy
catalinic philip lipsy
mike toms jennifer lind and takara
yamashi
so starting with michael okay thanks
um it was a great paper and a great
presentation you soccer thanks um
a couple of points first on uh christina
uh
mentioned that she was surprised that
there didn't seem to be any sort of
coattails effect
in terms of uh approval of the host
leader
and i'm wondering if that might not be
uh
and i guess part of the reason that's
surprising is because why invite
the visitor if you're not going to get
something out of it um
i wonder if if there might be
countervailing effects there
um sort of a possibility of a coattail
kind of basking in the glow of the
celebrity who's visiting
uh but also the possibility that you
sort of pale by comparison
uh in the joint press conferences or
whatever other sorts of events there are
and
you sort of end up in the shadow and
you're diminished
um and so i wonder if there's a way you
could tease that out
in looking at these at these surveys if
there are questions that might
may give you priors on sort of the
relative respect that the host leader
and the visitor have or something like
that
um to kind of get a sense that maybe
maybe there are effects working in both
directions
um but the the other question has more
of a methodological one
and that's um i love this i this natural
experiment
of did the visit um i'm sorry did the
survey response happen before or after
the visit started but i wonder if that's
actually if it's actually unambiguous
that that's really the best cutoff point
so especially in so far as media
coverage
is a big part of the mechanism on some
of these visits there's a lot of media
coverage on the run up
to the visit about the preparations
things like that and and that may affect
the responses
of people who are just answering these
questions in the gallup world survey
whenever they were answering them such
that that maybe the first day of the
visit is not the right
cutoff point and i wonder if you've if
you've moved that around
a little bit uh maybe maybe something
relative to when
when mentions of the visit really
started to ramp up in the
local media or something like that um
as as a the question of sort of when the
respondent in the survey was
kind of um primed by the visit
as opposed to the actual events of the
visit at that point it might
those some of those might even be
anti-climax at some point
so just wondering if you looked at that
thanks
hi so shall i just jump in
yeah so so thank you for this great
paper another stellar project
uh in this area from from you i i teach
your other work
um so i was excited to read this one
so i have two comments the first comment
is that
my colleagues at nyu have published a
paper that you cite in your paper
about why leaders visit other countries
and i know this paper this paper well
and they sort of make this claim that if
a foreign leader visits another country
it sends a signal
that they expect that the incumbent in
the other country
will be in power for the foreseeable
future
so a visit from a foreign leader can
help to prevent
domestic opponents in the host country
from
attacking the incumbent or criticizing
the income and trying to depose the
incumbent
so this suggests i was just thinking
about for your project
it suggests that you know leader visits
i mean you're not saying that they're
random
but it suggests that leader visits may
be more about
the need for fending off domestic
opponents
or the incumbent may sort of invite
leader visits when they feel weakened
or they feel like you know their hold on
power is tenuous
and i just wonder if it was worth
thinking about whether there's any
causal pathway uh potentially there
between the need for a visit and on the
part of the host country
and attitudes uh in that host country
toward
the sending country so that's my first
point and then the second point was just
conceptually i was expecting the
question to be
sort of more about the favorability of
the country or the favor of
the fact so the you know attitudes
toward the country or favorability of
the leader
but instead it's do you approve or
disapprove of the job performance
of the foreign leader and that just like
that seems a little
like people don't have views often of
the job performance of their own leaders
um let alone you know the views of views
of the
job performance of foreign leaders so
i'm just wondering if this is a
situation where
you know you never so like the public in
the united states never see
stephen harper doing his job and then
suddenly they see stephen harper doing
his job by visiting their
their leader their leader and like
shaking hands and get
and i'm just wondering if this is more
like people don't have information so
they are indifferent and then they move
toward having information which induces
a
a positive attitude and your results
seem
you know consistent with you know there
is there's evidence that it's
indifference
moving to to less indifference rather
than
people holding kind of negative views so
i just wanted to raise those two points
but overall
uh it's it's a really great paper and i
enjoyed it and i really
enjoyed seeing that picture of the
yakiniku thank you
um feeling quite depressed right now but
i think i think i'm next um so i also
enjoyed this paper a lot and i think
it's a really cool uh
approach to this question so so two
points um
so the first is about the kind of
substantive conclusion
um and and and just i think looking at
this from from an ir
perspective i didn't really buy
the idea that you know this this is sort
of a substantively important
effect which is not to subtract from the
paper i think the paper is fine
but kind of framing this as a sort of an
important big effect
i felt like didn't sit well with me so
it's it's basically a two percent change
in the public opinion of a foreign
country for
20 days um and so you know
that that kind of magnitude of change
could matter if you're running a
domestic election
with a certain kind of electoral rule
but it's
it's the foreign citizenry uh you know
and and that marginal difference is
really not going to have an impact
on any kind of policy outcome that we
care about
and so to me this the punchline here is
it does have an effect
but it's not really going to matter for
anything and
i think that's still fine in terms of
the paper because you're measuring
something
and it might have other important
effects but
um i i didn't quite agree with with the
way the paper was framing
the findings um and the second one was
christina's
comment i think i think very similar but
but the appendix k
coding of the the visits that came with
sort of a policy
outcome struck me as maybe being too
strict
like it seems like just subjectively
look thinking about
these visits there's usually some press
conference where the leaders are saying
you know this is what we talked about
and this is the progress that we made
and so maybe you know the coding is a
little bit limiting in that sense like
there weren't any of those that included
japan
and it's hard for me to think of a abe
visit that doesn't come with some kind
of
policy announcement right it raises
questions like why are they there
you know if if there's nothing of policy
substance
that's coming out of the meeting and so
i i worried a little bit there and so it
might be worth talking
you know maybe there are visits like
that um
uh but it it left me with some questions
and so maybe that could be addressed as
well um i have some more stuff that i'll
send separately a great paper thank you
great uh mike thomas is next um great
well i thought this was just a
fascinating paper i learned a lot from
reading it it was very thought provoking
um i have a bunch of comments but i'm
gonna
just give you kind of two clusters of
comments one about
moderators and one about treatments so
my moderator's comment is an effort i
think to connect the two papers on
today's
panel by suggesting
that a key moderator that maybe not
explored in this paper so far is the
politization
of a diet so if the first paper on
today's panel is correct then efforts to
increase soft power
including by diplomatic visits should
depend on whether the dyadic
relationship
between the countries is politicized or
not one way that you could test that
would be by estimating pre-existing
levels of
um hostility uh and
or favoritism between the countries and
or with the public opinion data you have
looking at the pre-visit popularity of
the foreign leader
as a measure of the moderator but let me
deepen that point a little bit because i
worry that your estimates are probably
an
upper bound on the positive effects of
diplomacy
um you describe what you're doing in the
study as a natural experiment
and i guess at some level whether a
respondent answers
the survey before or after the visit is
as if random
but the thing that's not random is the
visit itself
guests have to be invited and guests
have to
accept so let's suppose that guests who
aren't welcome won't be invited
and let's suppose that guests who think
that their visit might not help or might
backfire probably won't accept the
invitation
then those two things are going to limit
the generalizability of your findings
it's as if the subset of the visits that
we actually observe are best cases
uh for a positive effect of diplomacy so
anyway that's my attempt to connect the
two papers together
um my second comment uh is about uh what
counts as a treatment and
um i guess i have two small things to
say here but one builds on something
that michael
already mentioned um because he was
wondering what counts as a treatment the
first day of the actual visit or
something else
i have two suggestions there one would
be to actually
study the effects of pre-visit publicity
if you can
and the second would be to point out
that given the methods that you use
any pre-visit publicity effects are
going to make it
harder for you to detect the effect of
an actual visit so to the extent that
there's bias in the estimates the bias
is going to be against
finding an effect on the day of the
visit
and so even if you can't study you can
at least sign
the bias caused by uh not being able to
consider those types of effects
um the other thing that i was puzzled by
and the treatments
is that you find um it's based on the
graphs that the peak impact of a visit
occurred around 15 or 16 days
after the visit and then declined very
sharply in the next five days
so my question for you is what theory of
persistence and decay
could actually explain that kind of
pattern if for example the effects
persisted because they learned something
about the foreign leader then why would
they dissipate so sharply within five
days after day
16 for example so a little bit of
thinking about pre-treatment effects but
also about the post-treatment effects
and
how those could be theoretically
motivated i think would help strengthen
what's already an excellent paper
thank you great thanks uh jennifer lind
is next
hi everyone um so everybody's talking
about
this paper is great this paper is so
well written it's so clear
it's um it was just a real joy to read
so
seriously congratulations on really
writing just
a a model paper in terms of
it was so easy to take in and
you know i one thing that that you might
want feedback on
is is the precision and the models and
the statistics
i'm definitely not that person i'm not
going to give you saku
statistical advice but another thing
to to get feedback on you know i always
ask myself
what what do we now know about the world
after reading this paper and so um so
there i i can
definitely give you some advice um i i
guess i had
some of the same reactions as as phil in
terms of
um what have we learned specifically
about things that the the world cares
about
um i think you have to bolster that case
in the in the piece um
uh again the thing that the world cares
about
is how a country can persuade another
country
to do something this this notion of
through attraction or persuasion
and so on and you associate that with
and i think quite sensibly theoretically
was the concept of saw
power so so again perhaps the argument
is
a country that has more soft power
will be able to negotiate a more
favorable trade agreement
or will be able to convince its ally to
take on
more burden-sharing responsibilities for
example
um but again in the paper that
thing there's no evidence of that
there's no
evidence that the leaders public
diplomacy
affected this this outcome which is
ultimately the the outcome that we care
about
so i think you need to bolster that case
to
to address the fills and the the jenny's
who are in the
the you know your readership so um
so i think the place well one place that
you can do this
um is in the intro like on on page three
you talk about
public diplomacy may assist the state in
shaping
the partner state's ability to implement
a desired policy across a wide range of
policy realms
so this this notion that um it helps
the the other countries government build
the
case for being more helpful to the other
state and so on so i think that's really
promising but again
that's a pretty weak statement oh it
might do that
right so you gotta show us some evidence
that it does that or um
also on that page the the paper cites
different articles
talking about how public opinion uh
contributes to
a state's policy on a variety of issues
and then there are a bunch of citations
i think that's where you can
really um fortify
your case uh i think you really need to
build up the case
to to people who aren't familiar with
those papers and what they found and
what they argued in what context
because that's the key finding that
people care about that makes
this paper really interesting which is
if that leader visits and and gets that
resulting favorable opinion that's going
to lead to a better outcome a better
policy outcome
for that leader's country
um and then let me just quickly raise
two issues by the way i'm going to send
you
guys comments written comments so you
don't have to like write down
everything um two issues that i thought
were really interesting takeaways from
this paper that um
they're currently not kind of front and
center i thought they were really
interesting um
the role of the media as you you did
talk about
um the role of the the media is like a
filter plays a really important role
here
um it's the way that people learn about
the visit and
presumably there's a narrative that
that's told
um first one thing one question i had
was how do you
you have the figure in the presentation
about um
to the extent that there was media
coverage you know what are the effects
i was wondering how you operationalize
media coverage
um this this in general this made me
think about
uh in settings where the media or stay
controlled
uh does that mean that if
a leader visits a country with
state-controlled media
then that is going to
make it better or worse or so on is it
is public diplomacy still going to help
in those settings um and i think that's
a particularly interesting question to
ask in this
day and age where we're looking at a
rivalry between
an authoritarian country and democratic
one
and then a second point again something
that i thought was really interesting
from your paper that i would be
interested in you guys exploring
maybe in a different paper as christina
said um
i was really interested in the fact that
this was not helpful for the host
leader why not write that up
um i actually think a lot of us have the
sense just you know stuff we
come upon when we're doing our random
reading for papers
we we learn about like was it um
like helmut cole was up for an election
and so he wanted reagan to visit that's
when the whole like bitburg cemetery
thing
happened but i remember like reading
like hell nicole really thought this was
going to be
helpful for him to have reagan visit
it's really interesting if you guys find
no evidence
for that so again that strikes me as
being quite a different paper i'm not
even sure it's
ir as kind of is but who cares but
anyway
um i think that leaders do think that
this is helpful for them that it makes
them look
statesmanlike or whatever um and
you know at the very least if you don't
write a paper on it i think it would
make a really cool op-ed to be deployed
in an appropriate time
thanks
thanks uh caro is next hi so my point
was um
similar to well in
essentially the same as mike tom's but
it's um this
idea of selecting on the dependent
variable so i was looking at on page 16
on the paper where
you say you know because of the timing
of the gwp sampling
timing is not something that the
government will have taken into account
strategically that it's
as if random um i just wanted to clarify
that i think that
that is true but if we think of the
distribution of timing
before we you have sampled
relatively randomly here i think that
distribution might be skewed
on various things like a
expectations of host and recipient oh
sorry host
and visitor teams of
this being successful um the
host and that could entail things like
media freedom so if the host country can
control the narrative
it's a lot more it's a safer visit
it could be things like so yeah mike
suggested politicization level
originally
i guess sorry hostility level um this
kind of comes back to our paper too
because it's about how politicized
things are to begin with
um but i think one you can do these like
kind of like pseudo balance tests
um but it would also i think even if you
can't
you know stake balance
you know say that these things are
balanced with these various measures
just looking at randomly sampling some
of the cases
and seeing how these visits are actually
planned
like to me it's a warning sign that it's
very choreographed
no one would go if it's going to be a
true disaster situation
so actually seeing like if there's some
sort of risk associated with
going and so on would make the case i
think convincing in terms of the
overall distribution before you sample
great thanks so i want to take this time
to uh
read two quick q and a questions from
the audience i'll
uh kind of briefly give my two cents and
michael is your hand still raised
do you have dude you have another
comment michael tease
oh no sorry no okay oh tahoe also okay
um so let me let me uh i'll read these
two comments
um uh uh get my two cents and then we'll
go to uh
to tahoe um so from shoko watanabe in
the audience hi my name is joco
um i think the most important one of the
most important things of public
diplomacy is whether the prime minister
speaks good english or other languages
for example
uh prime minister abe used to study use
as c in his english and pronunciation
uh wasn't good if future prime ministers
can speak english well i think their
approval might increase more
uh another attendee uh noted uh
that they wanted to know more about
future developments in this research and
what areas will come
into focus i'll just briefly say you
know so i really enjoyed reading this
paper it's fantastic very well written
paper um
and really interesting findings um
and most of what i was going to say i
think has been said already i'll just
put a slave
i've maybe a slightly different gloss on
it which is you know first this question
well like seems like a core to
understanding the paper is what's the
big theoretical takeaway
um and i just wanted to know more i
guess about
uh the paper
has a little bit of the flavor of you
know this of
the reason the leaders are doing this in
order to increase foreign public opinion
but
as i mean and elsewhere you're careful
to note of course that there are other
objectives
for these leaders um but uh
you know it's as i think uh jenny and
phil are
pointing out it's not clear if it's
exactly
you know rational for years to go and um
participate in these meetings if uh if
what they're getting is you know this
two percent bump which is big
as you point out it's big and important
in the context of public opinion swings
uh but understanding the kind of payoffs
for it are
um for for the leaders and what they're
trying to be interesting i guess i guess
the way that i had thought about reading
this paper was
there's this really uh interesting bump
in public opinion that's probably not
the primary objective of these leaders
uh when they're making these visits um
and the other thing i just noticed you
know this question i think that
you know starting with uh nama raises
question about like what's happening in
the local media environment and
i just just even just some more
qualitative detail on that
in the paper that that explained what's
happening especially before the visits
and after the visits in terms of media
coverage
and for me would help answer that but i
really what a fantastic paper i really
enjoyed
i enjoyed reading it um tahoe
thank you i also want to thank for the
three authors
to provide a very interesting paper i
just want to
suggest you think about three kinds of
different state visits
one is a meeting between
enemies in this case you try to send
someone or invite to make sure
to agree to disagree in that case a
public diplomacy
will not be easy a second meeting is a
state visit between alliance or very
close friends
this meeting is planned already based
upon
a successful relationship president
obama's
visit or inviting president myanmar in
2011
trump's visit or invitation to abe
in 2017 so already
a public diplomacy is working well and
the state visit will maximize its
expected uh public diplomacy
final one is a tricky one send someone
or
invite someone to make your opponents
on your side or to drive a wedge
your visitor and the visitors alliance
shooting things a relationship with the
current south korean president
to drive a wedge between korea and japan
so future expected meeting between xi
jinping and the
japanese leader during summer olympic
game
or future xi jinping and the guidance
meeting
this one will be very difficult because
already
there is very small room for a public
diplomacy
so i suggest you think about the three
different meetings
thank you
great thanks um does anybody from
the the paper want to
respond to any of the comments
please yeah i mean an overwhelming set
of really really awesome comments and
questions and i
of course i really appreciate all this i
think it's really exciting to think
about you know where we can go next with
this project
in the paper um one thing that i'd love
to talk about more is
how we're interpreting these results i
think that we are not meaning to say
that
any leader could go to any public and
expect a positive effect right and we're
talking about
the incentives of the media and the host
leader and those conditions
i think we're precisely talking about
some of the selection effects that you
guys
are concerned about right so i don't
think that we mean to say that
because we find it in the sample that we
have we think that this
should you know apply to any potential
visit right is it would you say that's
right
um but
i i take your point very seriously about
how we should consider this a high
estimate and how we should think about
the distribution of cases that we do
have and
and how how that might apply
um i don't even know where to start
thank you thank you very much for all of
these feedback
yeah i'll just also say quickly thank
thank you very much this is
really really useful and important
feedback for us
um and the the points about the broader
broader theoretical connections the idea
ir literature is something we we tried
to
emphasize but uh clearly is not not
coming through
well enough so so that's something that
that i think we can
we can revisit um
we do i mean with the issue of the
endogeneity question and the and the
planning of the visits i did just want
to
maybe push back or ask for a bit more
comment on
on that point i mean
yes you know the visits are planned and
we and we acknowledge that and there may
be
consideration of how it will be saved to
be received
among the visiting uh the public in the
host country
but the i mean if there is an
endogenous effect there it's
it it is not exactly our treatment
effect in in the sense that
we may think the public would be more
receptive to the visit or the
you know the planners of the visit may
may think the public would be more
receptive
but you know if if the planning is well
we think relations are going well and so
opinion is already high or is already
focused on a particular country
that doesn't necessarily
relate to the before and after treatment
effect i mean
it might be that if a country is off the
radar or if there are negative views
about a country a visit
would have a greater effect than than it
would in
an environment where it's um you know
where the planning
planning has gone through and and the
case has been chosen the visit's been
chosen because
relations are already relatively good
uh i just wanna say thank you everyone
for all of these comments
and uh because i was presenting i
couldn't see you know the comments there
but uh
i look forward to reading all of these
after this event
great well i think with that we've uh
you know
on the u.s side we're heading deeper
into the night i know that some of you
are also
in uh in europe where it's already in
the middle of the night um
of course if you're in asia you're just
beginning uh what i hope is a good and
fruitful day so i just want to thank all
of you
for a really fantastic lively discussion
of these two papers i want to thank
uh you know kusaku um amy and uh ben
for a really exciting uh paper and
especially
the discussants uh christina davis
diamond green riley
uh tetsuo kobayashi um uh
uh maria repnikova
um and uh uh
uh uh it's late enough now that i'm
forgetting our
our third discussion uh professor
professor tago sorry foreign
um but thank all of you uh thanks all of
you for this uh great
lively discussion hope to see you all
again
hopefully in person in the near future
thanks everybody thank you
thank you so much everyone